le collège thérésien cadet a poussé en
pleine nature et pour les quelques 600
élèves de la commune dès l'entrée en 6e
on apprend qui était thérésien cadet
ainsi son histoire n'a plus de secrets
pour ses enfants de 6e 3
cette équipe des raisins cadet
il est né dans les environs nous avons
été Paul et même que ça il y a bien
réussi c'est assez études c'était un
professeur aussi un enseignant en
biologie en tant pédagogue et c'était un
très bon pédagogue
il a trouvé 7000 échantillons il a
laissé son nom ici pour pour qu'on le
suive chez sa voix
thérésien cadet est né en 1937 aux
Avirons malgré ses modestes origines il
est admis comme normalien au lycée de
Saint-Denis
il poursuit ensuite ses études
scientifiques à Paris
c'est au côté d'un médecin à la retraite
qu'il découvre sa passion pour les
plantes professeur agrégé en poste à
l'École normale de Saint-Denis il
rencontre Janine en 1963 elle deviendra
son épouse et sa fidèle collaboratrice
en 1966 il met en place le laboratoire
de biologie végétale de l'Université du
montfia sa thèse de doctorat sur la
phytosociologie de la végétation locale
et son herbier de plus de 7000
échantillons font encore référence
simple et discret l'homme se voit aussi
confié de multiples responsabilités il
fait notamment partie du Comité
économique et social du conseil régional
et nommé par le Premier ministre
membre fondateur de la strepen il est à
l'origine du classement en réserve
naturelle de certaines zones de l'île
comme la forêt de marlong à
Saint-Philippe
en février 1987 il meurt subitement mais
la renommée de ce spécialiste de la
flore des mascarènes et désormais
international